hello welcome to this video playing the
set integrator no name two wins or
losses against him no drawers yeah what
do I Cooper ship if I he I cannot really
remember let's not spend too much time
probably not a big difference they
usually play Bishop g5 i think uh huh so
we get some kind of benoni hmmmm night
before but usually this doesn't net so
much I just play Bishop you one and
night we'll go back really quickly I'm
always amazed how can people play that
in in the split second okay if I take
that I don't see it what's happening 95
for Bishop b2 or something some
completely crazy stuff
yeah oh come on that's working so you
won't you do this oky waited come on so
I have to take this first so now maybe a
three or what is he doing queen 85 and I
know what if i move the bishop you will
take take the rook a three that's
probably really create five and the did
this work probably create five
Jesus what kind of a position is that
yeah Queen 854 this work can you do I
don't know how he does that it like a
split second b5 and i def takes d5 but
it seems to work this is craziness um
III cooney 5a before Queen before you
and he has rupee aids also
remarkable
we should a six probably not night 86
ya know anyway doesn't matter this is
already toast here this position other I
mean he care if maybe blunders stuff but
otherwise I'm just an exchange down net
f takes d5 this is remarkable
yeah that's can only hope for some
miracle i just got c4 that will win 25 I
guess no yeah it's got many ways to to
continue okay yeah bishop age 60 will
probably just return the exchange but
anyway I'll go clean therefore if he
takes with the Queen
ok so this I a google Queen h5
all that one I should have gone Queen h4
was a bit more interesting
yeah unfortunately doesn't help at all
to win an exchange back you need your
only hope is some kind of chick made
yeah it's a it's a pin pretty awkward
pin unfortunately
time warning he's got Queenie Jade now
okay I threatened bishop she's six year
and not really not really my idea was
Bishop g6 but not that's not even
working yeah okay white resigns yeah Wow
how can you play b5 said quickly I mean
I probably just too bad a player yeah
probably he knew that motif or something
I mean you just don't play it at two
seconds of you even as some some kind of
you even as a grandmaster it feels like
a dish of you like I had this on the
board before
yeah it's really it's it's awkward
that's an awkward situation ok well the
computer is not impressed about this not
so much it wants to play three other
today but I was thinking that this is
not working due to this aha yeah I can
castle I don't get it why is that good
for what I thought he can take here and
he takes this I Bishop d3 is the thing I
didn't see that more ok that's my it's
not very it's not trivial and now wyd
wins with bashir age 6 so that ft 5
wasn't wasn't that great I was just
thinking that I'm losing after Queen 85
I mean this is otherwise I would have
played it the engine wants to play
Bishop a six and test that this this and
I ok five Wow supposed to be around
decoy well and now it goes to a black
advantage yeah yeah I'm just lost I mean
probably I should have played that other
thing just just just try just try it the
edge is lost is just too much material
hmm that before I'd be five wow I had
something to take note off shouldn't
fall into that one again ok thanks for
watching